hey hey good morning everyone
we are back gamespot live I'm here with
David I'm Richie and today we're gonna
be playing a little Tim Tam we have an
alpha build of the game and we're ready
to roll let's do it
David what's up man how you doing I'm
doing good I think we're I think we
think I got an X out of this is what uh
what I said let me
that page cuz it sees me
SiC alright David how you doing man I'm
doing great doing absolutely fantastic
we're back and this is a little joke we
had with you guys gotcha let's uh start
the game here I did begin now we're at
the point where we get to pick our first
temptin so good because we wasted a
little time there let's just hop in huh
there I am I randomly generated a
character with a cool pink mohawk and
his name is Rab I'm gonna turn this down
a little bit there we go that's your
character that's my character check it
out I got a pink mohawk and he's picking
up chicks at the library okay here is
our lineup now I wasn't sure if I wanted
to let chat pick our first Tim Tim or
David what do you think what do you like
what's going on well let's take a look
at the options right you got like what a
little stats you old rash type Oh
Krystal is a crystal temp 10 strong
against electric and mental what's that
supposed to be psychic yeah that's a we
leave answers like fire and earth okay
sick hmm let's go check out our other
options No okay yeah we got here Oh male
8 mm strong against earth and crystal
Oh bro but we can get semental okay and
then what's the last one let's see I
like what's going on over here looks
really cool oh it's a mental and strong
against neutral and melee but weak
against crystal okay
all right these types are throwing me
off for sure I would say dude I would
say just go with whatever you think
looks the my looks I'm gonna go right
here with our last one I were you forgot
her name the the the mental one who the
mental one Oh aha who she koushik who's
chick all right yeah let's uh holder
rename it anyway huh oh yeah why don't
you go with that one yes that's me Wow
yeah yeah squad I'm okay so what is HP
sta that looks like maybe stamina MSB
attack defense special attack special
defense oh my god this looks
what should we or should we name our new
who chic uh you want to give it a little
nickname yeah go for it hmm
Chad help me up I mean the meds yeah
your delay but how about
you know what it's a really hard
decision yeah it is this is way harder
than I thought and a wife how about just
Alex how about that Alex all right well
I smell it right yay all right we got
Alex sick let's go oh wait I redid that
the UM look you bought for these names
makes me think of like Sonic Adventure 2
battle Chows that's very specific yes I
do
oh cool okay so it's also controller
compatible which is what I'm using but
it works just as fine on the keyboard
we're playing the Steam version but
everyone run away all right did you just
dip yeah you did all right cool cool
okay you don't need the professor
outside let's go look at that here so
you you customize your character you
have like different choices to mess with
the hair and clothes
there were yeah there were options but I
randomized it mmm
you teacher's pet no is this right yeah
let's go see your meta title dude oh man
here we go against my rival is it in a
car yeah I've even capitalized our Alex
all right looks like I can kick choose
the target I am I'll go with the
mouseland kick you right in the face
you know what that was probably a good
attack against my body did one hit Wow
max has already taken the lead that was
weird
that digital tense of years really gave
you an edge yeah that hamer not the
tenth odd TV such a cocky yeah geez when
do we get revenge I'm already pissed off
yeah you know what I only had that kick
as an option the rest were grayed out
dude so the game kind of just set you up
for failure
like so I'm gonna say I'm gonna stick
with that story because I had an attack
first I had the opportunity kicked it
right in the face and still lost and I
still get a prize at least you're a
looker else do they have type weaknesses
and strengths they do but but the types
are kind of bizarre like we just went
the room right now when we pick the temp
Sam there's like mental in melee and
then like earth and things like that
crystal it's a couple of a couple of
other stuff Wow all right for losing dr.
Konstantinos gave me another tempting
yeah max is pissed off save it max you
already have your digital town set
whatever that means
Oh
[Music]
guys so salty I'm done with this
negative energy in Brickell tomorrow our
bristle the that seam of the little
thing it's like a Portuguese right
you two head up north and meet me there
temp cards and use them to capture okay
so those are like your pokeballs it's
gonna be hard not to compare this to
Pokemon that require absolutely right
it is a responding here there we go
shoo I thought the game froze right okay
[Music]
some balm thank you deep rooted I love
how they run away even the professor's
like SIA prudent kids I need a friend
here well I think that's someone else
that happens to be online because it is
an MMO right here's online like that we
look around here map point of interest
over here oh right the beginning of the
game started with my my ceremony my
send-off to be a 8mm tamer and she
missed it no problem yes I never noticed
you did you should just be like a total
dick watch this sorry I have to go yeah
get out of here watch if I had the right
conversation tree I probably could have
got a different voice chat mean running
around pristine coast dangers for
refusal on screen trouble it's not an
easy tour well you just got one shot
it's a we can yes we can agree to that
excellent okay so you guys are just like
farming yeah cool hairs win ward 4 kilos
yeah look at the pan something what is
going on so many names I'm just a little
loss but here's how we learn together oh
dear
okay
I'm with you there
[Music]
ah this is game also have a
single-player story mode I'm not sure
because I think the game itself is just
an MMO so this is like pretty much it
you know and I mean I believe there is a
like it is like the the campaign the
single-player mode but it shares it with
like everyone else right there are six
islands I read - gotcha got you okay
well all right let's go north then okay
there's a fight going on here great
right off the bat what is oh oh are you
been a 2d one yeah I saw that in the
trailer here okay see hypnosis those
highways those are actual okay all I
have this kick right now is I'm gonna
kick this in the face oh you can't use
your other moves
whoo no they were great out okay Oh cuz
it's like your mana you see that little
blue line whatever oh yeah yeah okay
just to be one level to tempt em bro I
did I feel like a bull yeah how do you
live with yourself asking the controller
alright well Wow
our first wild battle you got it you
gotta get out of that grass Steve
they're gonna they're gonna catch you
superfast the spawn rate seems very
aggressive alright
I was telling you to run is that an
option yes it is it is you wanna do it
well you get to be to them right let's
give it a shot yeah all right using kick
against this bird
and ugly soon wind blow yeah we'll knock
this guy out
[Music]
Wow oh maybe he's resistant so windblade
is he it's it there's a little hat or
coat first
yeah right oh for sure
Philip oh now you can use it okay who
give it a shot you wanna use some nosis
all right yeah use Peck heck we know
that works
Regan Stein asked they also evolved
right I mean I would assume so thank you
yeah they saw that in the trailer we
haven't seen any evolutions yet but yeah
for sure we won't about the mentally
wipe out bird it's the longer fight than
I thought Abdul Aziz asks how can I play
it so this is like an early alpha access
though we got the game itself is gonna
come out I don't know the exact day I
think it's like the 21st 21st yeah
January there yeah guys and it's coming
up to steam right like the PC it's
coming up to everything
ps4 step for mobile I believe okay yeah
nice crank me a little bit yeah hello
hello
you're gonna scare me oh alright one
bird down let's go with another king
let's just yeah just kick him out yeah
kick and peck this thing Zack azar yes
point on PC got him
wonderful sick getting the hell out of
the grass oh is that a trainer possibly
hey rad gone for a walk and the no no
I'm going to the Accademia oh yes you're
not what novice I don't know yeah I was
just running around I think this guy
wants to finally get out of your twist
Chad alright that's the pro tip let's
see if I can find it here we go I can
avoid the grass and still go north tops
great that's a regular in-game
challenger I believe yeah let someone
test my skill jefe the fish my guess
would be you're officially an apprentice
now jumping on me aren't you
nope now that started a fight now he's
pissed
oh man I don't know how weak my Tim
tomorrow
a good point I love that verb level-2
level-3 all right kick will kick this a
little peeking one big epic wind blade
you get one blade oh no no the bird
against bird doesn't work as oh it's all
good it's all good well it works a lot
less okay alright what do you think
David next move
try sideways yeah try slight wave on the
bird and - wind blade on the yeah that's
cool you can pick like you can just
stack your attacks on one time yeah yeah
nice no he's resistant to know my - why
that's it i Samantha welcome to the chat
yeah thank you guys for tuning in I
knocked that little pig out
my feelings hey man I wasn't starting
fights just got jacked anyway man look
at this guy Tim Tim Bob you 143
something looks like a Sun currency yeah
that's me all right this is this guy
waiting for a fight oh no he's also
probably fighting him too oh yeah oh
you're done dude I'm done for you only
have one symptom I should have healed oh
right they gave me healing stuff too
dang you're gonna make them late for
this sort of this a practical lesson
will be times we fighting oh no I'm in
no condition
there better be a run button no you
can't run forever
yeah there's no way I'm toast
well I guess we're gonna see what
happens when you get knocked the F out
it happens
let's see my health is okay but I do
have some balm to peel it all the way
resourceful many clubs and once your
temper that's just the cashier right so
there's no like revived yet yeah I won't
worry about the red first rich well okay
let's at least have a fair fight here
okay okay
my temp M is away cooler oh they already
knocked down my attack
[Music]
great okay well they can put one of them
this yeah yeah the other one yeah yeah
that's probably what you want to do for
sure no I'm not I'm not done attacking
no guys look so cute here we go
let's make this a fair fight okay nice
now kick the other one right in the face
there we go that's a good strategy
yeah yeah I mean they're just lowering
your attack though unfortunately are so
if you get a chance to use psywave you
should probably use that put a boat to
sleep right oh no the other one yeah
wave yeah yeah okay right which I using
sideways who the other ones awake now
rip
well knock out the first one ah you made
that one of them right yeah oh hey that
worked that was powerful sick sick sick
yeah oh you got this yeah yeah you're
gonna be fine
and we've been levelled up - oh wow is
he not the that first one out right I
did all right let's just let's try to
end this dick to the face oh you'd wanna
just act you to overexertion
oh you can't skip around my help
oh yeah yeah smart
[Music]
okay
oh alright another kick yeah that's like
my best visit I think it's my only
physical back
[Music]
I'll look at his health so close jeez
not again
all right well I don't have a move for
now no no I think I feel like you have
to wait it out what does that mean clock
yeah probably
waiting it out yep oh my help I'm trying
okay all right fine
yeah you can knock it out this should do
it you gotta all right after this should
I head back into town or keep going
north probably dude probably need go
back to town Heather temp temp is
knocked out this was rolled back come at
us we just did bro we don't call that he
got rekt okay you'll be a great tamer
one day thanks man
yeah there's a lot up north I'm gonna
head back yeah yeah no don't look at me
[Music]
oh no your spot I'm just trying to live
man all this cool hair
so I'm trying to remember your moves
against this one
oh right against the pigs wait can't I
really know what's that mean
this is doing oh it's like pickier
attempt Oh like swap them out or
something yeah well if we're gonna fight
yeah you gotta heal you gotta heal for
sure that's my first that's my opening
move
great okay nothing well there so it
seems like you're resistant against
their attacks which is good
uh-huh you know I'm saying like they're
using normal attacks yeah you seem to be
strong against it you go to sleep
I didn't am boozled great
[Music]
try that again okay good the effects
have worn off I don't know I need help
now again oh great
hey that's nice that happened to me last
time okay
what did psywave do I forgot the side
wave is like a special attack and it
seems to be of the mental type which
seems to just be psychic
essentially like pokemon psychic whoa no
it also seems like psy wave is probably
your stronger move than kick but it
seems like you have to wait until you
have enough of that like mana or
whatever yeah you know it I'm in all
right well we can kick this one or put
it to sleep what do you think well no
matter what it seems like you're gonna
overexert yourself you're right let's
just read it I wasn't kicked you could
just wait it out tbh because with this
you know like like just wait your turn
if you use any of those moves you're
gonna get you're gonna damage yourself
Oh like a hover over kick real quick you
see how how much it takes yeah you see
how it's taking away the blue oh yeah
because you only have three left and
that's gonna cost eight at least it's
gonna take that away from your health no
wonder probably more strategic to just
wait the turn look like a half damage
and then let's try it out yeah yeah so
you let your attempts um get some rest
good to know that little clock was not
very reactive but work we're learning
here and it seems like both have to wait
as well oh look that's the pig I pick
waited as well so yes I wait now let's
go for it okay
oh you bamboozled me in the last turn
what does bamboozle do it like makes me
not do my moves oh you just wait it out
let's try again yeah
why don't know giving my my tempt em
rest will shake off the effects of
bamboozling ready no yeah it depends on
um on how often is bamboozle right yeah
like he just used nibble yeah so go for
it go go for like [ __ ] yeah go do it
yeah yeah oh my god is hanging by a
thread
alright knock yourself out
all right
winner takes all yeah that's me boy II
valises I like the fact you can use
health to substitute as your MP yeah in
a sense
you know if you want to it seems like if
you want to make a move and you don't
want to wait you can just kind of eat
the damage from your health which that
was close help you get it right man have
to cross through the grass this fences
in the way once you go more left
I can't this a little oh yeah you do
have to go through the grass time here
we go yeah back in the town I need
supplies already it's hard out here for
like a like a Pokemon Center yeah these
three four buildings out here once you
go back to the lab okay let's see that's
the first building down there
Hey look there's like a live chat on the
bottom mm-hmm help professor for you
I ran graduation I think is just a side
story which is cool but I need supplies
oh that's another player check it out
okay that does nothing all right let's
try to find the store there was my house
and this building and then two other
buildings I didn't explore you looks
like another house yeah someone was here
I'm fine
goodbye hmm
why dig alas is this game on stadia I
don't think so not to my knowledge
I checked the official website and it
said every platform Xbox switch PC ps4
but I didn't see any mention of stadium
stadium mobile yeah yeah or mobile yeah
okay so there are no stores here I might
be doomed we have to we have to head
north yeah go for it I mean a your your
thing you're ten times a little stronger
now right and I think you've got a
better grounding of like the battle so
it has leveled up yeah so why don't we
just let's just Yolo it what's to the
right Oh
pretty sick out of my own oh okay can't
go up there I have to cut through the
grass all right oh yeah definitely up
and then to the right well here we go
nope okay
Jonathan Maureen's ask you what game is
this this is 1010
we're playing the brand-new mmo's alpha
on Steam right now a wild one charges
run for it yeah do you just did
oh no you can fail to run away I'm
doomed
no I'm not doing but just like a little
menopause yeah tenderness
yeah just record dude it's tenderness is
just gonna lower their attack when I did
you say me earlier okay that took almost
half as hell of a few more of these oh
[Music]
well everyone's going the Pokemon route
and asking just ask your mom to heal
which oh hi I'm a little tempted to try
that because if that works then like oh
my god yeah that's just I think we
should press on North I want to try okay
see that was harmless enough I can't go
right anymore have to go up yeah no no
yeah I think you had a you sure you can
go right yeah it stopped me oh right
here oh you're on a Ledge huh yeah to
the beach negative no some people are
saying you should try to catch some of
the temp jobs have those cards that's
right that's right why don't we try that
if you run into one yeah you know I mean
you up here you climb up that wall I
think so I'm probably gonna get caught
I'm pressing the button here no luck
that's all although yeah it absolutely
looks like I should be able said I rip
great Sara Sara and Laura why are there
question marks over their names already
there are there question marks that's
weird
we know can we are you whatever let's
fight yeah just yeah get it over with
this is hell yes man I only have one
left
Karl counts in I think a couple people
did ask about cosplay I don't expect
there to be any cross play yet just from
the nature of an MMO and the way that
this game kind of seems to be set up I'm
gonna kick this one because I know the
other one on the Left will only do not
visit all attacks yeah okay not bad homo
is his name shred Reaper says you needed
gear to climb probably how about here
I'm gonna be surprised yeah it seems
like it right oh yeah it looks like a
walnut in there climb yeah exactly
Oh bubbles that really hurt never
thought I'd say that sentence it's
really out I'm gonna kick this thing in
the face again
that one's gonna when I kick that thing
it's but it's not gonna hurt this little
great no it's lighter pouch okay let's
see few ways to go about this let me
just keep taking this one oops
the platypus temp temp sold me already
I've been wanting a platypus one for a
long I saw that on their Twitter that
what's called the idle member but it
looked it so cute like a little blue
platypus that's what we had on our
thumbnail I think yeah that's right for
the straight man one more kick - here we
go
seems like chats got a little bit of a
debate some people are interested with
in temps em others are kind of more
satisfied with Pokemon fine appreciate
you tuning in to check out for yourself
how it's going cuz who knows you may or
may not like this it comes out oh no
another one the full game release comes
out January 21st
Rafael bola go back to those items I'd
noticed those to you there's those
little grey boxes around on top of the
where I was supposed to climb yeah a
little bit to the right of it
oh okay hey by the way if you want to
take control after this I mean no I'm
fine I'm totally fine I'm just enjoying
a serving for sure
all right well I couldn't I was I was
wiped out and I only have three I
figured what it's called on the I don't
remember the official term but that's
basically your appeared like magic power
your mana oh boy all right well
everything seems to be back in order
here just rest I think you think yeah oh
yeah let yourself all right - oh great
wait
it looked like you used it on the room
[Music]
okay let's go try this one was good
you think against the pig what you think
I'm gonna go for it
nice no place kick how much is this game
it should be 30 bucks when you get the
full retail version what another one
this is for v1 wait yeah
oh that's like a that's not the Platypus
that we normally saw the blue one but
that looks like that maybe a different
room yeah
wonder if it's an evolution or there's
just a totally different type great
I should take care of this little guy
I've been here too long
okay the kick still does good even
though he's doing all those defensive
moves oh geez
I'm running out of balm that do anything
okay good whew yeah the game is not free
to play as far as we know this is just
alpha yeah we're playing really oh yeah
okay I think I'm gonna try that out you
know and uh krump was hurt I love that
name is there is there a type attack
bonus I can put one there does there
seems to be attack bonuses and attack
resistances as well so I think our our
ton time right now alex is like a mental
type that's the call it which I didn't
get your psychic and I've had or we've
had 10 times like use certain teams
against that that was like right oh yeah
or are you oh she like right there you
have the time steer so you just
completely worked that platypus correct
it so there we go let's finish this
little guy off use psywave on it right
earlier yeah idea yeah so that was like
double effective they're super effective
huh sick that was a really long battle
they just kept throwing out Tim Tim yeah
I gotta use all this currencies are
giving me too so you see that gray box
right above to the left over there yeah
if you got a left up and then to the
right oh yeah yeah that thing looks like
an item
you found a vital Apple does that do
restores 25% HP that's it cool all right
I couldn't climb that earlier yeah you
just keep a red shoe all right you sure
you don't want to give it a go these are
there's two of them in the wild all
right these look harmless enough but
they're probably gonna I might put in
some work oh yeah oh no you know what I
should have ran what am i doing oh boy
okay so now I'm poison
looks like the poison doesn't last
forever but I would I would definitely
Jam yeah yeah cool work last time it did
not it was embarrassed think it's like
failed to run away oh no I'm being
poisoned another trainer tamer they call
them yeah another change
[Music]
oh well they're just talking there right
yeah that's healing up before they go
all right all right next wild encounter
I will catch one EE our force is my
biggest curiosity is the crystal type ya
crystal type seems interesting I'm not
sure what that element is supposed to
kind of represent his mentals like
psychic earth is clearly ground or rock
there was like a fighting type melee
right they called me yeah okay that
Apple didn't do much
yeah it's only like 25% yeah I just want
to get it out of the way
Oh zero well we get to see what happens
when all my tempt em are out you've lost
the battle
okay you lost money yeah you drop money
is same in Pokemon cou like lose yeah
yeah you can get wiped out you'd like
lose half the money that's like kicking
me while I'm down hey well I think all
your guys are get healed out that's uh
check your spot wait that's just the
deck so yeah that's the next he'll be
back out and go yeah so squat here yes
what wrong one sorry the white one is
like there we go is the one I need to
click everything safe look they're all
healed
it seems yeah okay all right back that
Nora they kicked my ass back home all
right you know what this is a good
opportunity to try to catch a wild one
next encounter mm-hmm it's on okay but I
do want to get would you want to scoot
yup
next time it happens organically I will
right right
[Music]
was it up here was it blocked yeah was
no was
please music okay let's see two of them
are out I'm gonna try to catch that
poisonous one on the right yeah my full
squads back alright I'm gonna just kick
the crap out of the little menopause
thing yeah yeah rectum Metapod and try
to catch the little flower oh yeah I
forgot my little bird is back to it so
let's just pick on this guy first yeah
oh whoops hit the wrong one
no yeah I hit the wrong way I mean you
know he always gets it first
oh all right let's see here I want to
completely knock it out because I want
to try to catch it so I'm gonna keep
kicking it well I'm excited I want to
catch this one I'm gonna keep kicking
this one get it out of the way first
yeah I think you have to I mean in
Pokemon you have to knock out at least
one before you can catch the other
shared pain this is streams I keep
picking that one and it can't goes there
yeah maybe that's a maybe that's like an
ability or something that they have
right
maybe oh no oh man okay
all right windblade seems to know I
don't want to kill him again let's try
this done hopefully this kick does knock
I think it's gonna yeah well I tried
using my weakest attacks and I'm still
I'm not poison anymore all right well
next time any level Doug try again yeah
I do all right
that's right again now I really want to
catch one I just want it I just wanted a
one encounter yeah let me just try to
catch any of them yeah see what it looks
good
[Music]
not bad that move oh no I'm being stared
at
[Music]
let's sweet move
Lisa sounds that way lowers my attack
dammit
alright oh I can probably catch that one
I wonder what it involves into boom you
know what you think I can try to catch
the other one that do you think it's low
enough or [ __ ] what would you do David I
would let me try to catch one of them
yeah so why don't you let's just try it
out it's still pretty powerful it's not
in the red but that's right
and then peck the other one okay let's
see let's see if it holds
it's like uploading I got it oh yeah
census what you can release it right
away that's crazy
yeah just an open spot you're very good
and then you wreck the other one so this
is this is interesting because I'm like
I was pretty I mean I still kind of in a
little can't think of the word for it
but like not fully bought into this just
yet but it's definitely piqued my
curiosity the problem is that I keep
associating this with Pokemon obviously
it's hard not to like you said exactly
and so I'm like constantly thinking
about Kokomo strategies like Pokemon
trades
things like that and it's really hard to
separate myself from that but also this
is kind of me I'm like I don't know I'm
curious I will say that despite being a
huge fan of Pokemon for you know years
and years and years sword and shield
which I did really enjoy the starters in
particular I felt were not as strong as
previous generations and I'm very
curious to see how these starters kind
of evolved sorry I did a bird against
the bird move that way know what not bad
but I could have had a more record rats
James crow has a pretty interesting idea
where he's saying people who want
Pokemon they're gonna buy the tent of
constant matter wife and then people
really just love the genre and are
probably gonna go for both like him
which is a story for ego we're gonna
vote I'm gonna try this move out against
Oh both of them cool okay it's a side
wave of attacks both over the same time
but this one is are those real boys okay
guys whoa all right that's a new move my
little bird Oh No okay anos pretty
cool-looking would be a great game to
play with your kid yeah probably
I'm thinking so well let's finish this
little guy off I was gonna catch it but
I don't I just got one of these pájaro
there we go
oh good I defeated these guys I forgot I
wasn't fighting wild ones right and it
makes my money back yeah pretty much
we weren't even close that guy's name
was Sausalito oh cool who are you
Wow which one is who are you who are you
yeah
oh yeah he'll kill you shut up milkman
gotta go Wow okay okay so that's like
this is like the Pokemon Center yeah
also but lmao he's like nah bro my break
yeah here we go
why don't you talk to my boy over there
let's see oh I think I think that's the
box so you can back out of that oh oh I
see you like to store them
yeah yeah just candy and just back out
of that and maybe talk to the person
yeah see what he's got
if it isn't rad okay no so then that's
the store checkout try the far left out
of my way cool talk to that yeah there
we go
so just came to a check he's been with
us on our journey that's what I'm here
for a while bro chillin I'm gonna fight
me he's gonna fight me volcanion saying
can we move our streamers box a little
down so you can see the second temp
times health I would but I'm also a
little cautious of touching anything
right now because if you're here for the
beginning of the stream we the X the X
out of it so yeah my we might just have
to leave it up for now unfortunately
unless of you know how to move it
without breaking the huh it's I wanted I
don't want to test it out but I think I
might know how like it's really just
draggable if I remember correctly but
you don't want to
I don't want to keep it up I got oh
that's the frame us the frame itself
yeah oh you know what this doesn't block
that much you might have to hang in
there yeah yeah only because we don't
want to ruin the whole stream yeah we
got off to a bumpy start
yeah it was pretty hilarious whoo this
one's cool on the right yeah sorry folks
are ya the Troy trooper says it's an MMO
but it has a story
it does seem so yeah it seems like
there's like lore and you know trainers
teach me that are kind of thought about
what skill pretty much because you heard
there was a big campaign like Pokemon
but it's also a little correct let's
just wipe these guys out yeah and I come
out man you're on a roll
[Music]
did I heal okay no but I thought I gave
it help by doing that Oh bummer
[Music]
okay well that's cool too
solid wages ass and catch the Fox this
thing is so cute it was but it's also a
train I can't yeah I thought about that
won't lie to you let's knock this little
guy out and come we're saying Marty
liking the music it looks interesting
the music is already good dig in this
violin for the battle especially
defense up out of here no I'm sorry
oh cool love when that happens yup we're
both still poison not anymore
okay one of my boys
all right oh wow this is that full help
let's try our side way that seems to
work really well yeah sly wave seems to
be kind of like geared sometimes bread
and butter too is that it's it's tight
right yeah it seems like you're sometime
cement mortar specialist oh wow like
invisible ones great we're mates we make
a great team
anymore you want to throw at us
oh no okay good
no one's poison we're okay let's attempt
em up again I'm Moochi did man yeah it
so seriously like you just gotta [ __ ]
work man lost bro well then twitch adds
also fighting this guy here I think
possibly yeah all right let's uh let's
see where we are on the map Wow yep you
got quite a way
[Music]
it looks like there's gonna be some
secrets too just because you can't see
the map all the way from the beginning
yeah I mean like another flicking
Pokemon games rather you have to kind of
look explore if I'm walking like that
oh you got ether woohoo stores 20
stamina very good ethers usually a kind
of magic boosting the thing right maybe
maybe that blue bars what they actually
call the stamina oh yeah possibly you
let's fight now wait can we if you say
please oh I like that that's like a
badass no fight fine by the way this is
working with controller support but the
keyboard works just as well at least for
the Steam version which is what we're
planning on obviously Oh Mike both of
mine are a little low I have one bomb
left I'm gonna use it on Alex before we
begin the spikes and then
[Music]
there we go it is nice having both back
finally I was I was without Y for a
while there oh you know what though I
have my third one also remember yeah
yeah you do
oh no sparks okay it's raising a special
attack see I don't know what type these
are so looks like they're electric okay
maybe you liked your song or something
let's see how this works against I do
love this move I'm gonna try it again
yeah yeah no it seems like it's good
just cuz it's a double attack
oh yeah it's a boat
[Music]
yeah it almost looked like it like that
it was like yeah but it doesn't because
it's using sparks great it's just uh
okay
keep kicking this thing pickin him
peckin see although there might be more
attempt em no I think it's over bah you
[Laughter]
mean my money alright what do you have
to say for yourself we can all we can
all learn from him alright next one if I
find another wild encounter let's try to
catch it
wait do I have any of those cards
anymore how do you do yeah oh you yeah
watch this is gonna be another fight you
[Music]
yeah of course I knew
yeah yeah for example what do they
figure against fire come on hello
exactly are we done with this
conversation using against once are you
using against nature nature tempt him
yeah clearly so really nature supposed
to be grass or whatever is yeah like
anyway no theory oh I thought he was
just gonna let me off the hook I don't
know I'm kind of legal me hang kind of
leaning towards what you're grossing the
art of the temp them in the game looks
great the characters not that I think
some of these characters are kind of and
right now this thing is cool-looking
I'm gonna have to eat like it's like a
water type
[Music]
it's pretty powerful shits level lemon
yeah oh that that wind egg really not Oh
put him under or yeah you can feel - oh
yeah you have one more all right let's
try a stroke voice again I love this
attack and this one is this attempt M is
really hurting my Alex I keep pointing
what you guys can see but you know oh no
I need more foam yeah come on you know
there's about ready to attack do
[Music]
okay let's see what you can do little
guy these are pretty cool news it look
he has psywave to weigh no that's just
I'm sorry I thought we were focusing on
my other character Caro Caro stare and
peck okay yeah the guy yeah you don't
have any more problems luck you know I'm
so excited to get into town and buy some
although there was that little cart
remember oh we used hypnosis I mean I
made Pajaro learn hypnosis and I didn't
meet you again I think he's just gonna
learn that naturally yeah but I had the
option it was like pick which Oh Billy I
got you where are we and should I go
back to that guy who was selling stuff
so the guy who's selling stuff is right
I think you can make it all right if you
really want to yeah let's do I need to
buy bombs I have all this money to burn
Yeah right away dude I was like a pig a
pixel in no I want to run yeah you got a
dip
right for my life hey
now let's go rude no well we're about to
learn the hard way device
stock up okay hypnosis running a PLC
yeah very good call this is about to
fight it out okay the hell out of here
nice no tall grass that's very nice Oh
little hop nope no hop
little hop what what it's so far away he
can't even come to me
[Music]
you can't move I cannot move go
I thought those blisters like Annie - I
think that's great I told you man I
wasn't ready and that looks really cool
though
[Music]
metal Mad Men is asking how much can
they customize their character now you
customized them before we started the
stream so yeah I'm gonna customize hair
backpack all this clothes pretty much
anything you want not extremely detailed
cannot run we've got the fight
this one looks threatened man I don't
know peggeleh tag will work so much on
the third type whatever I got nothing
else except for that Oh way better than
I thought
no bubbles oh boy oh great well maybe I
can put one of them to sleep this guy's
being really mean no wait this guy does
the bubbles attack and I hate that so
I'm going to knock him out like that
little dance
[Music]
ya know is it worth using mine no I'm
gonna I might just die here in the
battlefield yeah maybe just take take
the El now and it'll just transport you
to the last safe Sun right with sham in
theory it should be that uh a little
light fight
Oh hopefully yeah I don't want to have
to go all the way back home yeah if it
goes to home and then rip what you guy
to who wins
okay that guy said he woke up what
happened I'm broke is this game Fritz
and I have it'll be 30 bucks yeah you're
at the hut so you're good
yes let's buy some stuff maybe I should
just died earlier okay don't have
anything to sell No yeah just buy some
[ __ ]
since I'm car there you got a bomb at
the bottom there we go
I was checking out what Center you got
about 622 so by wow I like maybe four
yeah go get him out at least maybe
goodbye one more okay go for it um maybe
one of these wait I forget how many I
had I don't remember
oh it says you have seven oh cool great
I don't have these what do they do
reduces untamed encounters oh okay
that's Joe yeah it's our repel it's a
repel basically to use I'll buy a few of
these great all right cool that's what
Jen yeah all right
don't use the hey did you like emo at me
oh yeah you can invis
and probably use your scent right so you
can just oh yeah you can just run run
through where my items back there you go
yep yeah wonderful SEC reduce not
related huh North allure northward bound
oh here we go
I wonder how long it lasts is there a
timer anywhere on the screen um in
Pokemon it was the amount of steps you
take oh but you get notified when a it
runs out oh so we'll see if this one
also lets you know what didn't I fight
these guys
no I didn't I don't member that lettuce
hair let's have a battle
I am Yoda and this is my daughter
agape I'm Ram those are just my usual
smelly hi Rabb let's fight then now
listen yeah yeah one vote choice the
town dude just go north I think a game
my uncle who played oh wow then you
treat me like a toy yeah there it is PC
as of just now chat is asking where
we're in an early alpha bill that's only
available on Steam
full game comes out January 21st yes I'm
done playing with you guys troit
schrieffer you're saying when you catch
the ball based on how long they've been
with you not what level they are that's
interesting
really that's cool yeah I'm not sure
that's like fully proving that yeah I
mean we'll find out how are they doing
Wow I barely heard them these those you
did shrill voice yeah yeah
oh there you go well got it back oh yeah
Vail's Oh Mike we're still poisoned whoo
okay it looks like I learned another
move
we know Opel yet quick mental attack
that exhausts the target for one turn
okay while it also it also damages them
so I'm gonna take out tenderness yeah
yeah you're at a tenderness there we go
nice sweet I wish I could just have five
minutes but okay let's uh don't you try
your new move sure to close out the
battle and if he's still alive heck
[Music]
oh very good
oh we're still poison good eyes anymore
that was fun yeah yeah 59 bucks now get
out of my way
well thank you he'll be better we better
ha we'll see now I'm not really okay
this is the conversation you don't need
me
with them okay do you want to use
another well let's try to make it to
town yes one more we're on limited time
here son of them okay we have a half
hour left this cool
do I know so what do you say to a fight
oh I don't have an option yeah yeah just
it's gonna you know kind of talk at you
and then occasionally you might get to
reply or something but the end games the
fight right right
it looks like that's an evolution right
there yeah the left yeah let's see
that's it once you take out the small
fry first let's try to kill you all you
want to do this yeah energy actually
here use energy on that one to kind of
block his attack and use wind blade on
them as well or no no no not one little
one a whoops fun on abuse kick on the on
that same guy to just kind of double
double dude IAM I'm pecked me yeah okay
let's do it yeah this one looks like way
more of a threat yeah so that's gonna
block him
for at least one round yeah he loses the
turn you get I heard them a little bit
more okay a little bit okay watch this
little bird like mess us up to the mat
oh wow what interesting maybe it can be
an offensive move possibly yeah let's
see are they
[Music]
and then shrill voice on the two of nice
I love I love that move
okay cool we got a big one thing here ah
heroic on Iraq
[Music]
Oh
the old Raven the ten SEM are trapped in
cards yes that's like the pokeball
they're essentially like digitized into
these cards we call one earlier and when
which he used is full I forgot what the
official name of the Tim Tim card time
some card yeah
and it was like it like digitize the the
time in a little more to capture it we
should we'll catch another one maybe we
should I already put the scent on though
I might be a while I just want to make
it to town y'all no longer asleep great
oh we got a new attack why do what does
it do I'm gonna get rid of oh it doesn't
hundred damage that's it Wow okay cool
and it's my fourth attack I don't have
to replace anything this is good nice
all right my little bird isn't getting
much exposure I think maybe I should
throw him in the lineup I mean he looks
bummed for a reason
let's go sick here in town I make it oh
wow one of my max
max was like our Gary he's about a did
we just made it here and in he's ready
spent extensive repairs
[Music]
[Laughter]
psycho dojo master all right that's like
because that means like we found our gym
leader yeah dude I'm like how that stuck
in my head just like I wish you wait ha
ha just meme it out dude I just get into
town and put all these responsibilities
are put on me
very well follow me friends oh good okay
historic tenants hem essence file no
Prentice should go without wants to save
them get it as soon as you can afford it
I know how much it is yeah curious she's
kind of just showing you the town right
now yeah me and max the Buster go away
quit following us and to go leg and
train the water sensor okay I don't have
any water ones yeah you're academia
[Music]
that's where I'm going to the dude calm
down man all right she's laughing at him
yeah no buts
[Music]
okay max leave us alone would you
temp or tiem okay that's your Center
slash mark official oh yeah face it I
wonder what the other one was then like
I was like a little Hut right it's
looking out post yeah but like what's
what's for sale in there but then an
adult we are adults okay
for once I agree with me so that's
interesting so you're officially like
that's your age is you're basically
adult secure I was kidding I think we're
like kids but that's just a man sitting
like no then we are I got sorrow desert
yeah look at all this kids have a great
game time to look around see ya here to
rabb loser
Wow I have a mohawk and you don't so
nevermind I am a loser
I think the let's go check out what we
weren't able to go I mean your quest up
over there says you have to acquire a
file of ten men oh that was the first
door let's just do that that was the
first building max just ran off jvu goes
I like how you don't just one shot
everything in have to use different
strategies every fight I think I mean if
we're comparing to poke fun I think
that's it's similar to be honest like if
we were five to ten levels higher than a
random you know encounter then we
probably one shot them to like you
you've wrecked a couple of lower level
time zones in the beginning yeah you
know like stuff yeah so I think it's
it's not exclusive to the game
I'm not on vacation I see
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible there it is you know what I'm
here for
sure one left this looks like where
Harry Potter gets his wand for the first
time the Ollivanders y'all Evander's
yeah it's potent stuff squad yeah a
family bro yeah give it for free let's
go I am let's see you are you serious
well I am serious
what about a surfboard just just say I
am yeah just take that essence I'm not
I'm not here to humor the surfboard bs
this game once right now
just give me my essence and let me go on
to the dojo yeah you have a Pajaro I do
that's a lovely birdie look at those
fluffy feathers good catch
okay thank Anthony goes free that's very
nice really care only one dose but you
can refill it out of he'll ten machine
at any time for you okay so if I go and
some other people have their own
supplies is it wonderful this heals all
of mine all at once
Oh gotcha so that's it that's your
revive basically yeah but like for your
entire team okay he's still asking about
him missing George I'm out of here yet
well actually sorry I may be asking
about the surfboard if you can cuz
you're maybe that's you being able to go
onto the water at some point okay then
whatever fine I bought it okay yeah ask
him again okay see you later
all right yes eventually basket asks
will this be can we place on ps4 to now
right now but when it comes out on the
21st it will be available on PlayStation
4 everywhere Xbox
everything except mobile is that
dethalian in chat or is that a fake
Italian I don't know sometimes you'll
see a checkmark if it's legit no and in
your game chat game yeah he's saying to
use twitch Prime that doesn't make sense
I think that's a fake no no I think
that's a fake off because he got moved
to mixer ok so that's probably someone
posing it so that's really funny
actually we can't hang out tonight I
should say oh come on let's hang out
tempting dude destroyed saying I'm just
ready for this I can co-op with people
yeah that should be fun I'm curious how
how co-op will work on the final release
comes out they are just kind of running
around here remember where we lost a
twitch at setup we lost him he was one
of our early friends yeah he moved on
[Music]
hmmm I think we just go to the dojo for
sure where was
this one yeah I think so oh that's oh we
have to go to Aris Ola whether you're
training at Sophia's surgeon on era solo
so that's that's more north okay here we
go it opened up a little bit
point of interest up there to the right
and then it dead-ends if I go this way
probably a lot more okay
Arizona they also said aerosol was up
north wasn't it
hi I'm Rev who are you so maybe we can
uh we can clarify if you know Richie
because there's some people saying so
earlier we were saying that it comes out
on this one first but when it comes on
21st is only for PC no no available on
Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC all on the
21st
I believe so yeah I did it I I'm gonna
double-check that to become one chat
saying that I think it's only for PC but
we know for sure it's coming out on the
consoles and stuff because the website
itself confirmed that right yeah yeah
you know what yeah it'd be good idea to
double-check eventually down the line
they plan for all of them but whether or
not one is coming out first is a
different
right right let me check out the
academia before I cool my next class
I made just school hi no I'm gonna head
north yeah I think a surfboard might get
me a little further away a little
farther away here right I'm gonna try
that other path where that point of
interest was gotcha so it does seem like
it's just PC on the 21st right now cuz
it's like an early access type thing oh
I'm glad you checked yeah yeah and then
the but it is confirmed to come out on
ps4 Xbox one and switch but that I think
that's still in development is what I
was seeing online
yeah there you go so that's the
corrections uh what were you saying
earlier yes thank you all right
butter go home said I just checked on
the mixer rechecking Natalia's uh-oh
he's saying this is a really good
audience on next year that's funny
then I'm curious why he would say to use
twitch crime is that that's like a
conflict of interest hey were you going
actually I needed to go to both of these
places well you're already at Bristol
d'marco oh right that's backwards no I
don't want to that's really funny well
here we go
[Music]
energy manipulation whoa one hit from my
little bird
ouch
level it up
oh no it's gotta be new temp them that's
all I need help man shrill voice yeah
just why not
[Music]
okay No Oh got him
shrill voice definitely feels like a
good bread and butter move
yeah you're facing a lot of to be too
you know and I mean yeah I had like one
one be too bad
please see you forget what works against
this pig really well
oh let me use this in a while
dang it I forgot I needed to take a
break
[Music]
say night
[Music]
see if it works on this guy and then
we'll use when very nice
[Music]
hmm that puts them to sleep let's try
this one again have fun sorry for saying
90% of the game is tv2 but it does have
one vtune etc yeah we saw some of those
like 1b twos like you're getting yeah I
really leveled up on early on yeah yeah
to Mateusz does seem to kind of be like
a the main thing okay everyone's tired
let's just end this battle what you
thank you damn don't look so surprised
guys like you would get out of my way
here we go if I a next wild one let's
try to catch it
Oh mrs. sunglasses over here I'm just
passing through let's discuss time time
halogens Wow you ready to lose
I need to heal these guys needless
insanity is this game harder than
Pokemon games I let it be the judge so I
was gonna we can both be the judge
because you're playing right now yeah
based on what you feel what are your
thoughts do you think I would put it
like maybe we're early on in the game
and right now I would put it equal to
that early game Pokemon kind of the same
like for sure I died like once so far
but I would compare it to at least at
this point I would compare it pretty
evenly to Pokemon right so I think to
Rich's point it's some like it's good I
wouldn't say it's difficult it's kind of
like if you guys remember for those of
you who have played Pokemon which I
would assume a lot of people have it's
kind of like that first time when you
play that book one right like getting
used to the rules of the game the laws
of the game the way things were damage
types kind of getting a feel for the
world it's kind of like that because
we're learning some new rules that time
time is introducing and some new
concepts that we didn't quite maybe know
before especially if you're comparing it
to Pokemon
you know a lot of the times right yeah
but I wouldn't say that the game is
particularly difficult yeah I mean like
you kind of got a hang of it pretty fast
yeah I did it's it's just as strategic
those Pokemon over they were saying
there's new rules new lingo small
learning curve but exact I need to
awaken it yeah but it's like if I can do
it I think y'all can too especially if
you know and love Pokemon for sure you
can take a lot of those strategies you
might have for Pokemon and kind of apply
it here
I like those sunglasses but I'm sure
there's a lot of things that obviously
we still don't know like maybe how other
types of evolutions work and you know
what I mean oh yeah there's probably the
abilities and things like that so I
agree there's probably gonna be a lot to
learn in the later game and spider let's
see no I'm like means that who needs
yeah my Tyra why Oh No whatever everyone
get some let's go hiding back there
behind this bald guy no I and you are
you don't remember me no I don't
remember you do Carmen doesn't ring a
bell
well it was many years ago man everyone
remembers my mother what have you been
up to show me what you have learned
Oh like she's fine things that's what I
was yeah catch up show me what you
learned
what are you bit up to we're gonna get
to a fight I shouldn't have to prolong
this
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
apparently have many friends who have
just moved on
tempt him up
[Music]
so far I think my opinion on the whole
Pokemon a clone debate which chats got
some pretty valid opinions on for both
sides yeah I think the thing is is that
the solution comes if you decide that
Pokemon as a game essentially becomes
its own genre you know what I mean and
if it does then you can make that
argument that subset is just another
title in that genre like you have you
were to compare I don't know maybe like
Capcom or smartville and some other sort
of TV to15 a fighting game you know like
you're using those elements the problem
though is I'm leaning towards it being a
bit of a clone because of the way the
tempt em appear the way that the game is
designed with you having these healing
sections the market the fact that you
have like one mom sending you off you
have a professor you have dojos yeah
which you can find a copy of that in a
Pokemon game the intro was so similar
for sure like you know starter Tim Tim
yeah oh yeah your starter temp cent
you're free that you can choose from and
they all have different types that like
kind of rock-paper-scissors
like I don't know you have to admit
that's oh absolutely
but the problem is though are the thing
that might like well I don't even know
how to phrases but like it's not a bad
thing that it's like copying those
elements but it's pretty direct so it's
safe to say like it's
Pokemon Cloninger but it's not a bad
thing as all I'm trying to say right
because I'm so having fun here and then
there are the differences of it being an
MMO like being co-op right and all that
kind of stuff it's coming out on PC as
well that is cool and like Xbox which
Pokemon is not right no so maybe this is
like scratching that itch in a market
for people who don't have Nintendo
consoles yeah doing just enough to like
you know sway some more people over
there or at least get Pokemon fans
rioted know why I was friends with this
person 60 bucks
all right so long Jim okay that guy was
in chat earlier whoa what is that
Pokemon attempts him that he has that
wow that's cool that's like a gold with
the gold like horse crystal horse or
sweet that's cool take it let's talk
that's a guaranteed trainer battle
before you wait maybe I got duped by the
thought bubble that appeared Oh city
slicker what is this I don't know if I
have enough sorry friend he's a bit of a
big city boy who know a city boy talking
all this smack I don't even know me geez
oh hang out let me anyway you got an
urbanite tamer in this slick city boy
he's new to these parts you get that
bumpkin enough okay yeah that's all I
want
it's tough time as it
bizarre uh he's got a what's up
those are got a huge check this wah yeah
alright well he's got two starters
interesting let's see here I need oh you
were wreck
yeah dude oh man you're done okay that's
tough you gotta put it all into my best
here
Oh God come on Alex lit well you know if
there's not gonna work there pull here
why don't you try I mean hopefully
you're ten times attack first but you
might as well just use the most powerful
move you have so use feather Gatling
because he's done he's gonna be done no
matter what you know what I mean yep why
don't you use it on the maze it's gonna
be effective on one and it's gonna be
non effective on the other yeah here's
how I find out
oh yeah he's my stuff first oh please -
I moved
don't kill me yeah I do have one more in
the reserve what a bummer what I didn't
oh it was used on me okay let's try it
on the other one
and then I can use tech for against this
guy what it won't let me use it for the
other to change their ego well see what
we can do sick
whoa oh that's super effective nice Oh
ability okay nice okay yeah he doubled
up on him good stuff good stuff so his
two kids Sam's down I could rename him
that I should know I learned a new move
with my little bird cool when Wayne nice
okay it tells you those in the middle of
a battle I kinda don't like that
let's see you so I don't know if that's
gonna be effective against you chick
yeah I'm tired you might as well just
use kicking it let's kick it
I can't oh you can't no wouldn't let me
I don't know if using that would work
either you know what
[Music]
yeah that barely didn't kick is not
effective either okay and maybe you do
hopefully you okay yeah did that did
some work on me
there we go why don't you use energy
manipulation try it and then some more
windblade yeah go for it
here's hoping yeah you're gonna get up
oh yeah he's got enough chance leave my
little bird alone never mind he whooped
your ass a lot of talk huh $79 whoo-hoo
it's back to the city boy yeah how are
you you fight a good fight
all right out of the way but how did she
avoid the fight here hey go back here
and fight these two oh that that chiz
involved Tencent as well that's cool
sweet why since we're before you go talk
to her because that's probably a trainer
battle since we're nearing the end of
the stream we are why don't you um if
you can let's just catch a [ __ ] yeah
all right let's let me deal what I got
first oh wait let me use that thing Oh
your shirt in my backpack
yeah it is yeah and you can um love for
everyone here
yeah won't use that and you can get
another one if you go to the yeah I just
gotta Lily what exactly all right let's
Patrick one for the stream we're
probably gonna have to sign out let's
see we go
o'night we don't have one of these yeah
what was it called Kaku Kaku let's go
all right I don't want to absolutely
whoop on it so I can catch it totally
just
let's do little things this girl's got a
good sort of outlook on it he's gonna
pick this up when it comes out but it
doesn't mean that he'll put Pokemon down
cause he likes to have no style there
you go toxic spores why don't you try
catching it yeah right now yeah cuz
those things are pretty uh your attempt
on cards are pretty strong for early
game you have a few right you have more
than a couple yeah oh why is it still
telling me to do this you know okay here
we go
[Music]
got him cool that's how it looks release
no part of our squad hey this cap and
his little Sammy Wow I don't know that
that's funny
well that's a good place to end it we
caught one more from the squad say
that's gonna do it for us you guys
awesome see if I can uh oh yeah go back
to I believe it
intro intro yeah hey uh yeah sick sick
sick sick thank you guys for watching
yeah let's turn there we go David thanks
for joining me dude ya know that you
were having man I was cool it was cool
tune in tomorrow we are back actually
don't know what's on the dock yet but we
stream every weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time tune in then it should be
cool man yeah yeah so it seems like a
good game for those of you are
interested the release date for this and
early access on PC was the 21st and it
will come out on consoles so ps4 Xbox
one switch but those are at a later date
uh but yeah they're planned not
announced yet not officially awesome
thank you guys for yet again yeah
absolutely
see you tomorrow
[Music]